go ahead and start oh all right
so yeah thanks everyone for coming and
thanks to the organizers for inviting me
so today I guess I'll be continuing the
theme looking at how we do computation
with lattices and here we're going to
focus on applications to commitments
signatures and zero knowledge and it
turns out that all of these different
primitives can be viewed through the
lens of holomorphic commitments right so
in the last 25 years or so we've seen a
lot of different cryptographic
constructions realized through lattice
based crypto starting from of course a
high seminal work on constructing
one-way functions and collision
resistance from the sis function and
since then there's been a number of
work/study new types of functionalities
that can all be realized from lattice
based assumptions we saw public key
encryption then we got identity based
encryption and in 2009 Craig Gentry gave
the first construction of a fully
homomorphic encryption scheme for the
first time from lattice based
assumptions and this has essentially
opened up the floodgates of new
constructions in instantiations from
lattices and the last ten years we've
seen an incredibly prolific line of work
showing how we can build things like
attribute based encryption predicates
encryption constraints pseudo-random
functions notions like trader tracing
and even non interactive zero knowledge
all of these different notions can now
be achieved from standard lattice
assumptions and in this talk we're going
to focus on this very very small segment
of this very general landscape we're
going to look at in particular
homomorphic signatures and impact and
their applications to certain types of
non interactive zero knowledge but it
turns out that the machinery that we use
so these homomorphic trapdoor evaluation
techniques that ho Tek and Rotom have
already pointed out and discussed these
can also be used to realize these types
of applications so without further ado
let me remind you what fully homomorphic
encryption allows us to do so in a fully
homomorphic encryption scheme the idea
is we want some way of ensuring
confidentiality together with
computation so what we can do is let's
say Bob here publishes a public key
Alice can encrypts any message of her
choosing and delegated to it
trusted cloud and what the cloud can
then do is take the encrypted message
and directly compute to obtain an
encryption of the function evaluated on
the message so the cloud can homomorphic
Li compute on the cipher texts and at
the end of that computation Bob will get
a cipher text that encrypts f of X which
he can then decrypt using his secret key
so this is a way of delegating
computation to an untrusted party while
preserving a confidentiality for that
the inputs to the computation informally
speaking the properties that we might
care about a secure key namely semantic
security for the message the ciphertext
hides the original message and also we
want an efficiency guarantee namely that
the final output the resulting
ciphertext only depends on the size of
the output of the computation and
essentially it's independent of the
input size or even the size of the
function so in okay so in all of the
years throughout this entire talk we
will model functions as boolean circuits
so when I say function you can think
about a boolean circuit so just as we
can compute on encrypted data we can
also ask for a dual notion which is can
we get integrity for computations right
so we can use fully homomorphic
encryption as providing some kind of
confidentiality guarantee for a
computation we can also ask for an
integrity guarantee so in this setting
we can invert the rows of Alice and Bob
let's say Alice has a signing key for a
digital signature scheme and Bob has a
verification key and what Alice can do
now is she can take some input X so you
can imagine this could be a data set
Alice can sign that input and give it to
the cloud and the cloud will then
compute some function on the signed data
and it can also produce a signature on
the sign data so that when Bob receives
the output the output consists of a
function evaluation the output of the
function so f of X which is denoted wise
here as always a signature guarantee
that this function was properly computed
so Bob can now verify a signature and
what if the signature verifies then he
knows that
the output why dakea pink is indeed the
output of evaluating the function f
analysis original data so it's a way to
provide integrity for computations and
just as a foodie homomorphic encryption
we can define various properties we
might care about so security is going to
essentially equate to unforgeable icky
so mainly if Alice signs and input X and
the cloud computes a function f then the
cloud should only be able to convince
Bob of the actual value f of X it cannot
reveal the signature for any value y
prime that is not equal to f of X so
signatures are going to verify with
respect to a value as well as a
particular function as similarly to
fully homomorphic encryption we also
require a compactness property which
says that the signatures that are
produced by the homomorphic evaluation
procedure should be very short it should
only depend on the size of the output of
the computation
it should not depend on the size of the
input or the size of the function so you
can imagine that the inputs can be very
large the function can be very
complicated but if the output let's say
is just a single bit then the signature
should actually be much smaller than
either the input or the function
evaluation all right so how do we
realize this well the way that we're
going to build this is starting from psy
fully homomorphic encryption schemes so
Hotel gave a really nice talk this
morning on how we can realize fully
homomorphic encryption and in particular
he presented the construction by
Gentry's the high-end waters so and let
me recall that construction here again
so in the Gentry's the high waters
encryption scheme the public key is an
lwe matrix
namely the columns of a are going to be
lwe samples and the secret key
essentially is the LWT secret and the
important property that we will use is
this equation that Kohoutek also
discussed which is that if you take the
inner product between the secret key and
the public lwe matrix a eventually it
essentially gives you something very
small so it gives you the noise term the
noise is assumed to be small so this is
approximately equal to the 0 factor so
this is one property that we will use in
this talk and so what does the
ciphertext look
like them well the ciphertext is
computed by essentially as a Reagan
encryption you take your public matrix a
you multiply it by a random short matrix
R and then you add to it x times G where
G here is the gadget matrix so a times R
is used applied and x times G is used to
encode the message itself so just to
remind everyone the gadget matrix here
is we'll use one particular gadget which
is the powers of two matrix so you can
view it as a as a rectangular matrix
where you have the powers of two along a
diagonal the reason that we like this
gadget matrix is essentially it's a
matrix that has a public trapdoor namely
given any element in Z Q to the M you
can use this you can use what's called a
binary decomposition operator the sample
was short preimage of the function
itself so mainly and we can extend this
from vectors the matrices so given any
matrix a G inverse of a basically takes
the binary decomposition of the elements
or the components of a this gives you a
short matrix such that when you multiply
again by G you recover the actual matrix
a ok so this will be very very critical
when we talk about homomorphic
evaluation next how do we equipped well
the encryption will use the fact that
this is an lwe matrix so if we multiply
by s you're going to get something short
you're going to get something that is
small so if we just multiply the
ciphertext by the lwe secret s notice
that we get s s transpose a term which
will vanish just by how we set up the aw
that public key and we are left with x
times s transpose times G so G here is
the gadget matrix another property of
the gadget is that lwe is actually easy
with respect to the gadget matrix and so
we can actually decrypt and recover the
original a message X and in throughout
this entire talk we can think about just
encrypting bits of a message so instead
of encrypting a large the Q element will
just encrypt bit by bit it turns out
that this is without loss of generality
okay so this is the syntax of the g SW
encryption scheme it's essentially just
a version of reggae encryption but the
interesting thing is that it supports a
very expressive set of homomorphic
operations so just to remind everyone
from techstop will eventually end up at
to it at there's a single equation at
the hotel there right so just to see how
those where those equations come from
and with respect to the GSW encryption
scheme let's take a look so suppose we
have two cipher texts one of them
encrypts X 1 the second ciphertext
encrypts the message that's true we what
we want to do now is we want to be able
to construct ciphertext that encode a
sum or the product of these two sniper
types so let's start on the easy side
how do we compute an encryption of the
sum of X 1 and X 2
well what we can do is we can simply add
C 1 plus C 2 and notice now that C 1 is
an encryption of X 1 with randomness R 1
and C 2 is an encryption of X 2 with
random is R 2 so if I simply add these
two cipher texts everything adds and we
see that we get a new encryption of X 1
plus X 2 where the randomness is this
function R 1 plus R 2 so R 1 and R 2 are
small to begin with
then their sum will be a little bit
larger but not by much and so we still
have a valid GSW ciphertext so sum of
cipher text corresponds to an encryption
of the Sun so second we want to do
multiplication and multiplication is
going to be a little slightly more
complicated I hear we're going to make
use of this G inverse function so this
is exactly the same multiplication
relation that we saw earlier this
morning
they need to multiply two cipher texts
we take that we apply G inverse to the
second ciphertext and multiply it with C
1 why does this work well let's just
looks at how the algebra lines up so
first if C 1 is a R 1 plus X 1 times G
we multiply a R 1 by G inverse times C 2
and then we have X 1 times G times G
inverse of C 2 but by the properties of
the gadget G times G inverse will cancel
out and we're left with X 1 times C 2 so
now if you just expand everything we get
that very precisely
another GSW ciphertext and encrypts the
product X 1
that's to where the new encryption
randomness is going to be so again
slightly larger but not by much
why is that well if r1 is short and r2
is shirk X is binary so X 1 times r2 is
still small and G inverse of C 2 well
recall the reason that we like the G
inverse function
Lachie averse outputs binary valued
matrices right outputs matrices with
small components so if you multiply a
short matrix by another short matrix
you're going to get something that is
still short and so we can now
homomorphic lee also multiply ciphertext
together
ok so this is everything here is just a
refresher from from earlier this morning
so now let's see what the holomorphic
operations look like you can compose
once you have additions and
multiplications to evaluate an arbitrary
boolean circuit on the encrypted values
so given C 1 to C n there is an
algorithm basically by composing the
addition and the multiplications it
gives us new encryption C sub F here
that encrypts F sub f of X with respect
to new randomness artists of f of X and
this is what I will call the input
independent evaluation algorithm and the
reason why well we distinguish it from a
second equation which is the main
equation that howtechs I mentioned which
is will depend on the input here
everything only depends on that
ciphertext so the public value c1 up to
CN as well as a description of the
function f and in fact this is the whole
appeal of fully homomorphic encryption
right we can compute on the cipher texts
without knowledge of the message right
so here I'm viewing the message as the
input here so this computation from c1
to C sub F this only depends on
components that are public it only
depends on cipher text and the function
f it is independent of the value X you
do not need to know X to compute this
quantity all right so with that we have
you basically have constructed a fully
homomorphic encryption scheme right we
showed how to do homomorphic addition
and homomorphic multiplication we shown
these algebraic transformations that
induce the corresponding homomorphism on
a message space itself so a natural
question to ask
is is this all that we have from the
scheme right and the very amazing thing
about the GSW encryption scheme is that
there is a second homomorphism that we
are implicitly using so we didn't
explicitly use it here but if we look at
it more closely and especially when we
look at the security analysis we see
that there is actually one additional
source of homomorphism not only are we
homomorphic lis computing on the
messages there is also a homomorphism on
a randomness on the encryption
randomness itself and the key
observation here and this is needed for
even a correctness analysis of GSW is
that when we do these homomorphic
operations we derive new cipher texts
with respect to a new set of encryption
randomness and the new encryption
randomness is actually a short linear
combination of the original encryption
randomness r1 and r2 so where the short
linear combination can have coefficients
that depend on the input X as well as
the ciphertext C 1 F 2 C n so what does
that mean so this was first formalized
and extracted and used to construct
attribute based encryption in a work of
o'may at all
well basically this homomorphism says
the following there's a public common
orphism it takes the cipher cuts and
produces a ciphertext that encrypts f of
X but what about the encryption
randomness of this new ciphertext this R
sub f of X well our here can be
expressed as a linear function of the
original are ones of Dardan and what is
that linear function well it is
precisely this function H sub f of F and
X so this is exactly the same H matrix
that ho Tech had in his talk so this
sort of it just a force falls out for
free from the g SW homomorphisms and a
very important property that we also
exploit it to argue correctness of the
GSW is that this matrix here is very
short so namely if you start with an
valid g SW ciphertext you have short
matrices are 1 up to RN if you multiply
by another short matrix then RS fear is
still short and decryption you're still
succeed so now let's actually try and
recover the actual equation
that we saw earlier today it basically
falls from just rearranging the terms
right so we can let's multiply this
equation right here by a so we get 8
times everything equals a times r sub f
of X and notice that a are 1 and a are n
are precisely related to the actual
ciphertext themselves right so we can
just replace a are one with say C 1
minus X 1 G and so on and so we now
recover the second equation that we saw
this morning and this equation I will
refer to as the input dependent
evaluation algorithm so give a matrices
C 1 and stop to C n a function f and an
input X we can construct this matrix H
sub f of X such that this particular
relation holds right so I just want to
contrast it with these two these two
relations so the first relation says I
take a sequence of matrices and they
take a function f but nothing about an
input X and I can construct C sub F here
I have a sequence of matrices I have F
and I have X as well and I can multiply
by this matrix H sub F H sub F X that
will produce C sub F the same C sub F as
in the first equation but - the
evaluation here and it turns out that
these two homomorphisms actually give us
a lot of power and has been used in many
settings to realize many different kinds
of lattice based instantiations so I
guess I have the same table that ho TECA
had at the beginning of today so
essentially we can use these two
homomorphisms to realize things like
attribute based encryption this is what
welcome described in her previous talk
we can use them to get homomorphic
signatures we can use them to get
constraints to do random functions and
essentially in each of these
constructions one of the algorithms so
for instance key generation in a b e
will use one of these homomorphisms and
a different algorithm for instance
decryption will use the second
homomorphism and they're tied together
by this pub by this clicks matrix C step
F so in this talk we're going to look at
the homomorphic signature application
which also uses the same underlying
techniques and ideas all right so we're
going to view everything
conveniently through the lens of a
homomorphic commitment and it turns out
this view is actually quite useful it
allows us to get certain kinds of zero
knowledge it also allows us to get
homomorphic signatures almost for free
which I would describe at the very end
of this talk so for the most of this
talk we will just view everything
through the lens of a homomorphic
commitment and luckily for us the GSW
encryption scheme already gives us a
homomorphic commitment so there's
nothing more that we have to do and why
is that
well let's take a look at a GSW
ciphertext right so here we have a GSW
ciphertext that encrypts the value X so
C equals a times R plus x times G so
what we can view is see here will be a
commitment X will show view as the
message that we are committing to so
what is the commitment opening well that
will precisely be the encryption
randomness now this is not very
surprising right if you have a public
key encryption scheme that is committing
that immediately gives you a commitment
scheme where the commitment opening is
the randomness used in the public key
encryption scheme so g SW has those
properties and we can reinterpret or
just simply sort of view
GS w as implementing a commitment scheme
where the encryption randomness itself
is the opening okay so instead of
viewing C as an encryption of excess
randomness R we can equivalently view it
as a commitment to X with an opening art
and to check the opening we simply
verify that it is short and that this
relation holds so this commitment scheme
has several nice properties first it is
statistically binding this follows by
correctness of g SW and in fact it is
actually an extractable commitment
scheme right because g SW as an
encryption scheme if you know the secret
key you can actually decrypt you can
actually recover the message so extract
ability immediately gives you the
statistical binding property and next it
is also computationally hiding this is
exactly semantic security of the
encryption scheme right the commitment
scheme is literally a encryption of the
committed message itself so
computational hiding or security of GS w
which follows under the standard lwe
assumption that making sure that this
commitment scheme is hiding
okay so once we had this commitment we
know that this is this is exactly PSW
I've done nothing fancy yeah I've just
been redefining things essentially or
moving things around well it inherits
all of the properties of the GSW
encryption scheme namely it is a formal
morphic commitment so what that means is
the following so suppose that I commit
to values x1 up to xn right so here we
have a yes so if you drop a question so
so what about this generation of the
public key that's an excellent question
so this is a commitment stream in a CRS
model so we assume that the public key
is honestly generated yeah so basically
there's a set up algorithm that
publishes the public key in this case
the public key will have to be a lwe
matrix and if the public key is actually
malformed or generated with knowledge of
a trapdoor then both of these properties
may not hold anymore yeah so this is a
commitment in a CRS model
excellent question okay great so what
does the homomorphic properties allow us
to do so suppose we have commitments to
the bits of x1 up to X n what we can
hope for or we can use a homomorphic
commitment to achieve is we can now open
this commitment to any function of f of
X right so in a standard commitment
scheme we'd have a commitment to a
message and we can open a commitment to
that message in a homomorphic commitment
one more question oh yeah oh can you
explain under which assumption is the
commitment scheme extractable so this is
extract ability is an information
theoretic property so basically if the
matrix a is correctly sampled
mainly it is this lwe matrix then the
lwe secret key there actually gives you
an extraction trapdoor so this is an
information theoretic property
assuming that a matrix a was sampled
correctly can this be a dual-mode
commitment good so yes indeed this is a
dual-mode commitment this we will come
back to at the very end of this talk
when we say how to get homomorphic
signatures so
suggest a foreshadow let's say something
half an hour from now we will say that
when a the uniform random matrix a we
can say sample a with knowledge of a
trapdoor the trapdoor will allow us to
build an equivocal you commitment scheme
namely you can open commitments close to
0 and 1 and it turns out that an
equivocal homomorphic commitment gives
you a homomorphic signature so that will
require a little bit more tools we will
have to talk about lattice trapdoors but
we will get there at the very end of his
talk
excellent question ok so back to
homomorphism on that on the commitment
scheme itself so a homomorphic
commitment says I can commit to a value
X and then I can homomorphic ly evaluate
on those commitments and then open a
commitment to a function of the original
value right so here I committed to X and
suppose I want to open a commitment to a
function f evaluated on X so the syntax
here will be the following so the open
algorithm will take in the public
parameters so just going back to rounds
question we have a common reference
stream or a CRS the public parameters is
that CRS it takes in a commitment and
then it takes in a function and then a
value and it takes in a commitment
opening and it tells you and it is
basically checks whether this opening is
a valid for evaluating this function on
a commitment to obtain this value so
what the binding property says is the
following we cannot open a commitment
with respect to the same function but
have two different values right so tip
so the standard binding property says
that we cannot open a commitment to two
different values yeah we have a
homomorphic commitment so you can
evaluate any function under values
themselves so when we define the binding
property we also define a with respect
to a function f and we say once you
choose a function f there's only one
value for which you can open up the
commitment the correctness property will
say that you can if you have a
commitment to X and you evaluate the
function f you can open it to f of X so
this basically says you can only
essentially open a commitment to y
equals f of X and the application that I
will describe of this it's basically a
notion of non interactive zero knowledge
it doesn't give you fully
non interactive zero knowledge and the
usual
sense it gives it to you in a weaker
model called the pre-processing model
which I will introduce very shortly so
before we do that before we talk about
the application to non-interactive zero
knowledge let's just let me just make
sure it is clear how these homomorphic
operations actually happen and how we
open up these kinds of commitments so on
the left here I have my homomorphic
commitments to the bits of the input X
and so given the commitment c1 up to CN
without knowledge of the committed
values I can compute a commitment to f
of X right so this is the public
evaluation algorithm this is just
ciphertext evaluation in a GSW
encryption scheme so if we look at the
structure of this commitment well it's a
commitment to f of X where what is the
opening the opening is the new
encryption randomness after performing
the homomorphic evaluation so from the
perspective of a user who commits to an
input X how does that user open a
commitment
well they precisely use the ciphertext
evaluation or the input dependent
evaluation procedure so they have the
openings to the original commitments are
one of the are and and if they want to
open a commitment to a function f
basically they will just multiply it by
this H matrix here and and this will
produce the new commitment opening so
how does a verifier check that a
commitment was open correctly
well the verifier can compute the
commitment to f of X and then it just
checks whether it is opening satisfies
the original commitment relation and
that this opening is short so with these
properties so just to remind you these
are the 2 main evaluation criterion the
verifier that checks the commitment
opening is going to use the public
algorithm to compute the opening we're
going to use the secret algorithm ok so
this gives us a homomorphic commitment
and we can open up the commitments very
efficiently so how do we go from
commitments to proofs right so so I'm
going to down describe an application of
homomorphic commitments to constructing
certain heights non-interactive 0
knowledge from standard lattice
assumptions so at a very high level the
idea
why commitment seems to be connected to
proofs is suppose we have the following
setting we have a prove or we have a
verifier and approver wants to convince
the verifier that some secret statement
X satisfies some relation R right so
this is still a hypothetical scenario
we'll bring it back to non-interactive
zero knowledge for empty very shortly so
how might we use a commitment to
facilitate this kind of protocol well
one thing we can consider doing is we
can have the prover commit to a value X
with respect to some public parameters
so we'll assume that there is some
common reference stream so there's what
some set up that generated this common
reference stream and now the prover
wants to convince the verifier that X
satisfies some property so the prover
will can commit to X the commitment is
hiding so this HEIs X and now if the
prover wasn't convinced say tell the
verifier that this statement is true it
can compute an opening to the commitment
of the relation evaluated on X right so
if it wants to prove that some relation
or some predicate holds for the secret
value X instead of opening X it can open
the value of the predicate evaluated on
X and essentially we can view that this
opening is almost a proof that the
commitment or that this relation holds
for this particular statement so there's
quite a few details I'm sweeping under
the rug so this does not work by itself
we'll we'll catch it
eventually but it is just sort of the
intuition for why there's a flavor of
some kind of proof system already
implicit in a notion of a holomorphic
commitment
what is the verifier do to check well if
it wants to check that the statement X
satisfies this relation it can take the
commitment to X evaluate this relation
on it so the relation we assume is
public then it derives a commitment to R
of X and now it's going to check that
the prover actually provided a valid
opening to R of X so if R of X equals 1
and it is an opening to 1 then a
verifier accepts otherwise the verifier
rejects ok so how do we use this basic
intuition and actually derive from it a
non zero knowledge proof system so let's
try and build non-interactive zero
knowledge directly from this observation
so take your favorite MP relation so if
you go out and look at art so the Hat
takes this statement takes the witness
and suppose we want to the prove our
school is to convince the verifier that
the statement X is true without
revealing any information about the
witness so I didn't define zero
knowledge here but zero knowledge
basically says that whatever the prover
sends to the verifier the verifier there
exists an efficient simulator that can
simulate the proof given only knowledge
of the statement and nothing more
okay so how might we use a homomorphic
commitment to implement this kind is to
get some kind of non interactive zero
knowledge like object well and that's a
simple idea might be something like the
following well assume that we have a
common reference string which will be
the public parameters for the commitment
scheme and we'll say well approver is
going to commit to the witness for
double for X right so the prover is
assumed to know the witness the prover
will commit to it if the commitment
scheme is hiding this should hide the
commitment and it should hide the actual
witness and now how does the prover
convince the verifier that indeed this
is a valid witness well I can compute
this function basically the empty
relation that has the same an X
hardwired inside it right so this is now
a function that only depends on a
witness it has X hardwired inside it and
notice that this is a function at the
verifier notes right the verifier knows
what statement is being proved so the
verifier can compute this function so
what the verifier can do now is it can
evaluate homomorphic li this empty
relation on a commitment itself and that
will produce a commitment of the empty
relation evaluated on X and the
committed with miss W and the verify
will simply check that this is indeed a
commitment to the value 1 so let's take
a look at the properties of this
strawman protocol so let's first look at
zero knowledge so zero knowledge at a
very high level so minimally it says
that the proof better hide the witness w
so why why would this hold for this
protocol here well first we know the
commitment is hiding so if the
commitment scheme is computationally
hiding then this commitment here cannot
reveal any information
the witness w we can review we can
replace it with a commitment to the
all-0 strength for instance and this
will be computationally
indistinguishable so for computational
zero knowledge
this thing's okay and then we also need
to argue that this opening of the
commitment scheme also does not leak
information about W so this is not a
property that is true right now it turns
out that this can be fixed so just take
my word for it for now at the end of
this talk I will say how exactly we fix
this but for now we will I will just say
that there is a way to open a commitment
in a way that only reveals information
about the evaluation of the committed
value but does not reveal information
about the original commitment itself so
namely this commitment here is opening
can be simulated just given the empty
relation evaluated on a witness and does
not require information about the
original witness itself so it's exactly
the zero knowledge relation so this
protocol as I described it here can
actually be shown to provide zero
knowledge unfortunately though soundness
is what breaks so soundness intuitively
we wanted to follow for the following
reason suppose and in the first message
the very approver generates a commitment
to some value we did okay so it is a
solemn honestly generated commitment if
that is true and X is a false statement
then this function that we are going to
compute this empty relation with X
hardwired decided this is the
identically zero function yeah so if it
is the identically zero function then
when the verifier computes on this
commitment C of the C sub W is computing
the identically zero function and so
this commitment that the prover produces
is always a commitment to zero and if
the commitment scheme is statistically
binding then we did statistical
soundness this proof system so if the
commitment was correctly generated it is
actually a commitment to some value W
star then this protocol would actually
give you is statistically sound proof
system namely because the the prover is
computing the identically zero function
on the committed value and it
in order to convince the verifier it has
to open a commitment to 0 to the value 1
which it cannot do unfortunately though
this is assuming as something very very
strong namely that this commitment
scheme is honestly generated and
unfortunately we do not know today how
to construct a how to have a mechanism
to guarantee that the commitment scheme
is honestly generated so here is a very
interesting open problem can we
construct the non interactive zero
knowledge proof that says that a regular
cypher text or a GSW ciphertext is
well-formed
namely given a ciphertext and a public
parameters there exists a short matrix R
as well as a bit X such that this is a
valid ciphertext just to make sure that
I'm following here so you're now in the
setting where supposedly the prover
wants to cheat I mean taking somnus
right yes and you're saying so he's a
cheater why would you why would you
assume that he generated a commitment to
something that's not a witness in an
honest way right make sense but if
somehow this treaty improver was forced
to at least do this step honestly then
we would be ok yes then yes so if we can
guarantee that the initial commitment is
actually a well-formed commitment to
something then we can appeal to
statistical finding of the commitment
scheme to argue that the proof system is
statistically sound good ok but if the
prover does not generate this commitment
in the honest way then we have no
guarantees this sort of motivates the
study of can we build a non-interactive
zero knowledge it was another question I
think so what do you need to show in
order to show that a commitment is
correct isn't this just proof for
instance of the bounded distance
decoding effect it is so and is it proof
for the boundedness
as the coding problem I think what also
suffice to show music for empty isn't
this something that is known at least
for sufficiently large values of the
parameters we know that that the
interactive truth and non interactive I
think it should be as a result that
gives us a music for BDD where we have
an official Coover so this is this is
Vinod there is a music for the
compliment of this language in fact a
statistical music but we don't know and
is it for this language I mean we not
mean we now know it from lwe all the
recent works on Piazza Mir right so from
here we can do it but before that if you
rewind to 2018 I suppose you don't know
so so the commitment is a commitment
right so it's still bindings and that
you know a cheating prover will not be
able to generate a commitment that you
know put both ways okay so what is the
difference here say what is the yeah so
so in order to argue soundness there
were actually two steps right so if the
commitment was indeed a valid commitment
then after you perform the homomorphic
evaluation that evaluated commitment
will always be a commitment to zero
but if you don't have a valid commitment
to start with then when you perform the
homomorphic evaluation you can't argue
that you always get a commitment to zero
it's possible that you get a commitment
a commitment is a matrix which is right
that's right yeah
yeah but you may not be able to resolve
it directly to a particular value like
there's no binding property if the
commitment is not is not the well formed
if there's a couple of questions from
the system you can decide whether you
want to hit them now or if you think
timing wise it's better to move on okay
yeah so maybe we should move on and then
I can take some more questions about the
offline afterwards okay right so so just
sort of motivate this problem if we have
a simple music by a direct construction
of a music for this something we can
actually get a direct construction and
non-interactive zero knowledge for MV
and this would essentially assuming that
this music here it makes only blackhawks
use of crypto then we would get a
construction of non-interactive zero
knowledge for general MP languages from
lattices and it doesn't need to make non
black boxes of crypto so the beautiful
theorem your approach gives us a music
for general NP languages from the GUI
but it does require evaluating the hash
function on a cryptographic object okay
alright so so here we sort of suggested
this dream version if we had this way of
proving that the commitment is
well-formed then we can actually
leverage this hormone-free commitment to
do some kind of zero knowledge proof but
we don't know how to realize this so
look natural next question to ask is
well can we still use this approach to
get some kind of zero knowledge system
and the answer it turns out to be yes
but we have to relax the model a little
bit so instead of working in the
standard crs model we will have to work
in what's called a weaker pre-processing
or correlated randomness model so let me
introduce this model and then say how we
can patch this instruction so in the
pre-processing model or the correlated
randomness model we're going to assume
that there is a trusted setup that comes
at the beginning of time and it
generates a proving key and a
verification key and it gives the
proving key to the prover it gives the
verification key to the verifier and
thereafter the prover can generate
proofs of arbitrary statements and
witnesses with respect to the proving
key and a verifier can use as
verification key to actually check the
proofs
so the importantly this is a relaxation
of the common reference frame model in
the following sense this is simpler
because we only require soundness to
hold
assuming a verification key is hidden so
the verifier has a secret approver has a
secret and we're assuming that the
Salamis will hold against approver that
doesn't know the verification key and
correspondingly zero knowledge doesn't
hold assuming that the verifier does not
know the proving key
so both the prover and the verifier have
secret state so we can view the CRS
model as the case where both the proving
Keys and the verification keys are
public and part of the common reference
string in this case and a pre-processing
case setting then each have a secret
proving and verification so the main
requirement that makes this model still
interesting it should be reusable namely
the setup algorithm should only have to
be done once and it generates a proving
key in a verification key for the
program verified respectively and
thereafter they can prove an arbitrary
unbounded polynomial number of
statements without needing to run the
setup algorithm again so in many
multi-party computation settings this
actually suffices for those types of
applications of zero knowledge okay so
how do we use how can we take this
general protocol and use it to get a
zero knowledge proof in this model right
so the challenge that we had ran into
before is that we did not know how to
prove and this commitment is a valid
commitment right that there is some
value that is associated with it so what
do we do well let's consider the
following strawman approach we want this
to be a valid commitment then everything
else follows so we don't know how to
have the prover prove that it knows that
this is a valid commitment we will
instead move this proof to the trusted
part so suppose for a moment that the
trusted set up is going to generate the
commitment to the witness as well as the
opening and now we don't have to worry
about the commitment being well formed
or not it's generated by a trusted party
is assumed to be well formed and the
verifier has this commitment and so all
we have to do now is have approver
output the opening to the MP relation so
a value opening to the empty relation
evaluated on the committed witness so
now this avoids the soundness problem we
sort of assume that because the trusted
party generates the original commitments
we don't have to worry about fooling
that those commitments are well-formed
so that part of the protocol
is fixed but we run into a different
problem now the pre-processing gear
notice is now witness dependent namely
this trusted party
what it generates at the beginning of
the protocol is actually something that
depends on the statement being proof
right and we wanted this trusted party
to be a one-time set of cost one-time
setup process and it should be
completely statement independent you
should not know about what statement or
what what witness has been used in
particular if the prover has to go to
the trusted party to get a commitment to
the witness every time it wants to prove
a statement this is no longer a
non-interactive protocol so to address
this problem
vo it suffices to just add one
additional layer of indirection so the
key idea now is the following instead of
giving approver a commitment to the
actual witness we're instead going to
give the prover a commitment to an
encryption key K and the prover will
also be given the opening to this
encryption key tape okay and the
verifier is just given the commitment to
the key k and now why is this useful so
the first thing I want to note is that
this pre-processing now is completely
statement independent right it only just
samples a random key K and approver is
given and honestly generated commitment
to this key K so and to actually
generate a proof of some empty statement
now what the prover would do is it would
first encrypt a witness using a key K
the approver knows this encryption key
approver will encrypt the witness using
the key and now what does it do it's
going to generate an opening for this
function f that has the statement X and
a ciphertext this encrypted witness
hardwired incited and what this function
f does is at first uses it takes as
input first of all the decryption key
and it basically takes the key uses it
to decrypt the Associated ciphertext and
that evaluates the empty relation on the
statement and a witness pair okay so
this function has the statement X and a
ciphertext hardwired incited it takes in
a key as input uses the key to decrypt
the ciphertext to obtain a witness and
then uses the witness to check the empty
relation
so this is essentially just checking the
empty relation on an encrypted witness
so notice that this function here the
specification of this function is
entirely public and only depends on
client ease known to the verifier namely
the verifier knows the statement and it
knows the cipher cuts so it can compute
this function f here so the verifier can
take the commitment to the key K and
holomorphic Li evaluate this empty
relation checking function on this
commitment and then it checks that the
approver can actually open this
commitment to the value 1 so why is this
protocol now sound notice that if the
statement is false then this function f
here is the identically zero function
because the function f computes the
output of the empty relation where for a
false statement X by definition there is
no input and will cause the empty
relation so as long as we have a valid
commitment to the key K which we do
that's generated at the second time then
once we evaluate this function f on that
commitment we get a commitment to zero
and so now soundness follows by
statistical binding of the commitments
key the prover cannot open a commitment
0 to the commitment of the value of 1
why does the raw knowledge hold well
zero knowledge holds assuming that the
commitment is the key K and the opening
also hides K so again we have this
caveat where we need that this opening
is also zero knowledge that it doesn't
leak information about the key so again
I'll sweep this detail under the rug we
will revisit it in a few minutes in a
couple slides but if we assume that the
commitment scheme and the opening hides
them encryption QK well then the
ciphertext that encrypts the witness
will hide the witness by semantic
security of the underlying encryption
right so essentially instead of
committing to the witness is the physis
that we can commit to achieve and if we
can commit to a key then we can actually
build a non-interactive zero-knowledge
in this setting
so overall non-interactive
zero-knowledge scheme in the
pre-processing model then works as
follows so the setup phase basically
just generates a commitment to f ck as
well as the encryption key and the prove
our secret key is the Oh
and the verification key is just a
commitment and in fact if we look at
this picture
notice that the verification key is this
commitment and this commitment is also
known to the prover so there's no reason
that the verification key has to be
secret so everything I described here
can actually be used to construct a
publicly verifiable proof system where
the prover has a secret key so in this
for this reason we call it a designated
prover non-interactive zero knowledge
from home or commitments so this is sort
of like a dual of the designated
verifier setting so that's again a
verifier means there's a secret
verification key and it doesn't get
approver setting there's a public
verification key so anybody can check
proofs but only a designated prover and
generate proofs okay so any questions
before we move on so I'm going to talk
about how we get that zero knowledge
property so does it matter what
encryption scheme we use so this general
framework does not depend is agnostic to
the choice of encryption scheme so any
semantically secure encryption scheme
will suffice it does matter when we talk
about the parameters so if you have an
encryption scheme with low depths then
we can actually use a homomorphic
commitment that's the forced load that's
computations so it does matter in terms
of what assumptions and what parameters
we use who is that we get from the final
instantiation but the general framework
is agnostic to the choice of in
traditional take the stream will have a
dual mode version or is it inherently
unique commitment to be statically
binding so you can switch to commit you
can so the commitment is dual mode you
can switch the commitment to a homeowner
'[ __ ] signature but then you still you
still you lose then you lose the
soundness sound this gets downgraded a
computational soundness and zero
knowledge is still computational because
of the encryption scheme so there is a
dual mode but it seems like it's a
strictly worse so the commitment scheme
gives you statistical soundness with a
signature scheme you get computational
soundness and computational zero
knowledge because we're still relying on
an encryption scheme to hide a witness
but you can imagine some comedy one more
encryption right it's efficient to
compose to give you a new or more
prepossession is it
good question I have to think about that
a bit I don't think it so when we were
trying to do this I don't think it gave
us a it gave us a direct approach so I
think the best we can do from this
technique right now is statistical sound
this computational zero knowledge and
it's not clear to me that that we can
get this old woman but it's an excellent
direction can you repeat where RK is
used by Fianna proof good
so RK recall is that opening to the
commitment to the GK and what is the
proof we look at it the proof is an
opening to the function s evaluated on a
committee G so recall that to compute an
opening to a committee with the function
H or we multiplied by the matrix H sub f
of X so that's where arc is used okay
great okay so there's a few more details
that I swept under the rug
so let's come back to those details and
that will also give us homework
signatures as a by-product so recall
that the requirement for zero knowledge
is that the opening to the commitment
scheme hides the committed value up to
what is revealed by the function of x
right so in this case the function or
site in this case X in our zero
knowledge construction X is the secret
key f of X is the empty relation right
so the empty relation it just outputs
one if the statement is true we don't
want to reveal information about that G
so this is not true as written because
if you look at how the opening is
computed is a function that depends on X
as well as the original openings to the
commitments themselves so as written
this can leak a lot of information about
our one of darayya so this by itself is
not context hiding so what I mean by
context hiding then so I'll give an
informal definition for the sake of time
and we basically want to ensure that the
public parameters this matrix a is here
as well as the commitments and the
openings can be simulated given only
without the function that we computed
and a function of value f of X so given
only F and f of X we should be able to
simulate the public parameters the
commitments and the openings in
particular we do not require knowledge
of X so this had a very zero knowledge
flavor as a very MPC flavor type of
definitions so in order to realize this
we will need one more ingredient so we
will need the notion of a lattice
trapdoor and I'm not going to go into
details here I think shredder gave a
really nice talk at the first lettuce
bootcamp on how these gadget crackers
are constructed and how they operate
so I'll just describe the main
properties we care about so here we will
just use the gadget trap force by
daniele increase which basically a trap
door for a matrix a is a short matrix R
such that a times R is equal to this
gadget and it turns out that this
trapdoor has many useful properties one
property that we will use here is that
it enables us the sample free images
under the sis function subgroups so here
we have the sis function takes in a
vector X and computes the product a
times X / Z Q so what what a trap door
for a allows us to do is it says given
it some element that's in the range of
this function and if you choose the
parameters accordingly this is a
surjective function in which case you
can save given any element in there in
the co-domain and the lattice trapdoor R
we can actually sample a pre-image such
that a times X prime is equal to u and
the important property of this is that
this cream H is actually Gaussian
distributed over the set of solutions to
a times x equals u okay so particular
there's a very nice Gaussian distributed
distribution over the solutions that we
are sampled so this is the only property
that we will rely on here so the second
thing I want to point out it's supposed
now that we have a matrix a and the
matrix a is the concatenation of two
matrices a1 and a2 it turns out that
there are actually many possible
trapdoors for this matrix a I will just
describe two of them turned out to be
very useful
so suppose first that we have a trapdoor
for a1 right what does that mean that
means I know that a 1 times r1 you post
a gadget then we can actually extend
this trapdoor to attract over any
extension of a1 so in particular by just
concatenate 0 I still have a useful trap
door for the concatenation of a 1 and a
2 right so a so Phi sister
no a trap door for us sub-matrix that's
the first observation and the second
observation that I want to make is that
there's another way that we can come up
with a trap door for this matrix a which
is if we know that a 2 is a short linear
combination of a 1 plus the gadget
matrix then our to this short matrix
here can also be used as a trap door for
a namely we just take our 2 and the
identity matrix here and once again we
get the gadget matrix G so whenever we
have we now if we have a trap door for
the matrix a now we can use this pre
image sampling idea to sample pre images
of any target vector u so that they're
distributed in a Gaussian way over the
lattice or over the set of solutions
where ax equals u and so there are two
ways a sampling from this particular
distribution and whenever you have two
ways of sampling from a common
distribution that often times is very
useful for cryptographic applications in
particular you will use one of these
methods to sample in a real system and
one of these methods to sample in a
simulation so let's take a look at how
we can apply these techniques to the
setting to get a context hiding along
with the commitment so to simplify
things I will just describe how we
handle the case where we can only open
commitments to the value 1 so if you
have a commitment to 0 you can't open it
if you have a commitment to the value 1
and you are able to open it notice that
this already suffices for 0 knowledge
because and zero knowledge we only open
commitments that actually satisfy the
relation and you want to consider
general functions there are many ways to
do it a simple way is instead of
evaluating the function f we can
evaluate the complement of at least one
of them will have the value 1 ok so why
is this useful now so suppose I have a
commitment to the value of 1 that means
that this matrix a concatenated with C
sub F when we evaluate this by the GSW
evaluation F of x equals 1 I get a times
R plus G and no more over R here the
opening to the commitment is short so
what does this
so if we have a trap go for a we can
sample short preimages
in this lattice right or if we know the
opening to this commitment and it is a
commitment to one mainly we know this
our sub f of X here then the committer
also has a trapdoor for this common
matrix so what we're going to do is
we're going to include a random target
vector u in the public parameters and
the opening is going to be a short free
image such that a candidate with the
evaluated commitment times V is equal to
u okay so if we have a commitment to one
you can sample this free image by using
the trapdoor based on R sub F and if in
a simulation we don't we don't know what
this value is we know what a is we have
a trapdoor for a we can also sample the
pre image V so let's just look at what
the scheme looks like now so in a real
scheme we have our public parameters
which is the lwe matrix a and we have a
random target vector u the commitment is
just g SW encryptions of the input and
to open what we do is we Sam we compute
the we homomorphic we evaluate the
function f under commitments and that
will give us the matrix U sub F and then
we stamp or pre image in this target
lattice a defined by C sub F and the way
we do so as we use the trapdoor that we
get which is the commitment opening
itself how do we simulate this right so
now the simulator notice is only given F
and f of X so the first thing we're
going to do is we want you have to give
the simulator a trapdoor for a so it
better be the case that a actually has a
trapdoor so it can't be an out of Yui
matrix but luckily for us under the lwe
assumption lwe matrix a is
indistinguishable from a uniform random
matrix a which we can stamp or a
trapdoor for right so instead of
something uh you know the beauty matrix
we're going to stand for a uniform
random matrix now how do we still choose
the commitments we don't know x i here
but i here we can just stand for random
uniform random matrix c the reason we
can do this is because if n is a uniform
random matrix r is short and has enough
and
we can appeal to the leftover hash lemma
and say that a times R is actually
uniform and this is a one-time pad
binding of x times G so the commitment
can just be random matrices they do not
depend on the input X and finally how do
we simulate the openings well we can
compute the target lattice defined by C
sub F just by computing on the
commitments I guess me just by
evaluating on the commitments that gives
me C sub F and now what is it actual
opening well is a short preimage of U is
a short preimage v such that a times C
sub F times B is equal to u and because
we sampled a using knowledge for the
trapdoor we can use our trapdoor
accordingly and so notice now that in a
simulation everything only depends on
the value of f of X and not X ok so
going back to the question about growth
there's a dual mode property so we look
at this context hiding transformation we
noticed that in a simulation we switched
the matrix a from lwe matrix to a
uniform random matrix a it turns out
that this notion by itself it's already
also very useful so if a is uniformly
random we can have a trapdoor and if you
have a trapdoor we can in we can
actually turn this into an equivocal
commitment scheme namely sorry that's
right so this is equivocal because if
you have a trapdoor for a you can sample
a short art such that a times R is equal
to C or a times R is equal to C minus x
times G right this is exactly the
property that we're exploiting in a
simulation like we don't know what the
value of x is but it doesn't matter
which again we can still simulate the
value for f of X using this equivocation
trapdoor and moreover if a is a uniform
random matrix here we can switch a to a
lwe matrix this will give us a
computational the binding commitment ski
right because here if a we know is lwe
matrix we know it's statistically
finding so we can switch from a uniform
random to out of Yui then we get a
computationally binding I think I'm
running out of pipes
let me just briefly introduce
homomorphic signatures so we're
basically there so if we have if we have
a uniform random matrix name here we've
said that this commitment scheme is
equivocal namely you can actually sample
openings to both commitments to zero as
well as commitments to one
this is equal occasion trapdoor can be
used to obtain a signature so the
verification key in this case for the
signature scheme is just a random matrix
a with the knowledge of a trapdoor as
well as c1 up to CN and the signing key
is exactly a trapdoor for this matrix a
so just to be very brief
so the verification key is exactly the
same as the forth is that we just have
random target matrices and the signature
is essentially the same as a commitment
except the opening is the commitment now
correspond the signatures we can now
compute our signatures because
signatures are commitments is exactly
the same GSW evaluation procedure we
compute on the openings or the
signatures and that gives us a signature
on f of X so to verify now a signature
anyone can take the verification key
take the function this defines the
target see Silla and they simply need to
check that a times r plus f of X times G
is equal to C sub F so I'm Forge ability
now follows from the binding property so
this commitment scheme is
computationally binding we get
computational unfortunately okay there
just to summarize everything I talked
about in this talk really boils down to
understanding and analyzing the
structure of g SW cipher texts and in
particular
interpreting or viewing g SW cipher
texts as a homomorphic commitment see
so the g SW ciphertext has a remarkable
amount of homomorphism and particular we
had these two master equations one of
them tells us how to evaluate just on
the commitments or the cipher texts the
other one depends on the inputs and
gives us a way to derive a relations
between evaluating on the public
components and evaluating on a secret
components and the two different methods
of instantiating are this commitment
scheme so for instance if a
as an elder beauty matrix then we get
extractable commitments so statistically
binding computational hiding today is a
uniform matrix that gives us an
equivocal commitment which in other also
gives us homomorphic signatures and in
both of these cases both homomorphic
commitments and homomorphic signatures
they allow us to build designate
approver non-interactive zero knowledge
so let me conclude with a few open
problems so I mentioned the first one
can we have a music proof of well for -
of GSW cipher text without points
through theorem here so I should clarify
that given that we sent that spectrum
here can we do it more directly can we
without making non blackbox you know but
there's also several questions related
to homework signatures and commitments
that I want to highlight so a very
interesting question here is can we have
fully homomorphic commitments or foody
homomorphic signatures from lattices so
in a case of homomorphic encryption we
assume circular security we can actually
get fully homomorphic it turns out that
for in a world of commitments and
signatures we can only get level
homomorphic commitments and signatures
so we have to have an a priori bound on
the depth of the computation that we can
support and the reason really boils down
to this H matrix here right so the norm
or the size of the entries of this H
matrix actually scales exponentially in
the depths of the function that we're
computing so you have to fix a bound on
a function f and then we have to choose
the modulus so that is much bigger than
that found in order for correct mr. holt
so trying to get some kind of
bootstrapping for a fully homomorphic
commitment or a fully homomorphic
signatures is totally open right now and
finally another one another drawback of
the existing construction of homework
commitments and homomorphic signatures
is that we have very large public
parameters right so if you've considered
a homomorphic signature scheme if you
want to sign an n-bit message the public
parameters consists of n random matrices
right and these are very big of course
we can compress them by deriving them
from a random Oracle but can we do so
without relying on random Oracle's and
with that that I'll conclude though
thanks for your attention and I guess
I'm questioning can takes up
[Applause]
so David one question for the short
public parameters the recent work in the
a B world where you can generate your
public parameters can be somehow sort of
independent of the number of is the size
of the attributes that you're so and
this is very similar to what you're
trying to do so I wouldn't be surprised
I think you know not thinking about it
too much not having thought about it too
much I wouldn't be surprised if that
machinery can answer you yeah very
natural direction so certainly we have a
B I guess it is your work with this
because right later it's something
better you know so one of the two you
know yeah so it would be interesting to
see if there's a similar machinery that
works
so my conjecture is that they should but
I don't think it's that it has been
verified and if I may ask now that I'm
here it's the second question so is
there a way to formulate your first
question the the direct and is it proof
in a more formal way and by which I mean
the following if you try to sort of you
do fiat Ramiel you embed some sort of a
bad challenge function in it and I would
sort of lattice trap doors and something
like that so I'm not sure I'm not sure
how to think about it as a non black box
use of crypto because everything you're
using here is so lattice like anyway so
it's not like I'm using a sort of
one-way function in a well so when
you're you're bad challenge function
that bad challenge function itself is
defined with respect to a cryptographic
primitive right true but it's not it's
not just like it's a lot less primitive
the lattice like but I guess you're
doing it twice in some sense right
you're evaluating the relation
attractable
ash function that is like primitive
itself yes all right
but I don't know how to formally kind of
you know it when you see it that's right
yeah that's a good question so yeah I
don't have a succinctly I think a
formally specify but I guess something
that's yeah I get to the edge Rand says
it's okay that's it
okay to be different from justify yeah
okay you have a couple written questions
David if you want to take them now or
offline it's your choice but after that
I think we all wrap up okay let's see
[Music]
yeah so maybe I'll pick those offline oh
I guess there's a lot more so what does
it mean for short public parameters so
let's say public parameters that do not
I need to scale let's say scale sub
linearly in the number of in the size of
the increase it's already interesting I
think